(audience applauding)
(mellow music)
- I'm not kidding. I know.
I could quote so many "Frasier"
episodes for you right now.
Whenever I found out they were
rebooting it, I freaked out.
- Did you?
Wow. (chuckles)
- Yes, I'm not kidding.
- Thank you. (chuckles)
- The level of wit, the comedic timing,
the physical comedy, all
of it, it's all there.
And I think it's one of those...
Not to dog any shows now,
I just think there aren't
really shows like that now,
so I was so excited.
Why did you wanna reboot it now?
- Thanks.
Well, it seemed like
the right time to do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Six years ago, the "Roseanne"
show kinda came back.
- Yeah.
- And then it was a big,
big hit.
- Yeah.
- And I thought,
well, you know, "Frasier"
hasn't gone anywhere.
He's just sort of drifted off into the-
- He is a part
of our family.
- The mist.
- Yes.
- Right.
- I love him.
- And it seemed
like a good idea to bring him back
'cause he was always funny.
- Yeah.
- And he had a nice take
on the world, and he loved the world,
and he wanted to make things better,
so it seemed like it was a good time
to step back into the role.
- Yeah.
Did you...
'Cause your voice, I mean,
just one of the greatest voices,
speaking voice, singing...
It's just a great tone.
- Oh, thank you.
For me, that's a big compliment.
Thank you.
- Well, it's a gorgeous tone
that people like dream of.
And did you always...
Did you always think you
were gonna do the theme song
to "Frasier"?
Was there ever any other idea?
- Well, what I did was, I said to them,
the producers at the time,
I said, "Oh, by the way,
I am gonna sing the theme song."
- Is that what you did?
(audience chuckles)
You're just like, "Oh."
- Yeah, and they said,
"Well, we're not planning
on making a theme song."
I said, "Well, maybe we
should plan on making one."
(audience laughing)
- I love it. I love it.
You're just like, "No, no,
I have this (indistinct)."
- So we ended up
with this sort of weird hybrid song.
It doesn't have like a middle
verse or anything like that.
It doesn't have like-
- Yeah.
- A whole story to tell,
but it is that sort of jazzy sting thing,
which seemed really
appropriate, and it has
become very popular.
- It's so appropriate
for Frasier Crane.
It fits so perfectly and it's
in everyone's heads forever.
I love it so much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for singing it with me.
I was very excited.
- Oh, it's my honor, honestly.
- And I just love-
- Thank you.
- That jazz vibe,
like that whole setup-
- Yeah.
- Is so fun to sing.
- Well, we changed it
a little bit for this incarnation
of the show-
- Yeah.
- Because I thought,
well, he's a little wiser,
he's a little more mellow,
he's more comfortable in his own skin.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so we should like lower it
and kinda ease into it a little bit more.
- I love that.
So that was purposeful-
- Yeah, absolutely.
- The new arrangement
for new "Frasier."
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love that.
I hear that you always have...
You must love singing.
You always have karaoke at your parties?
- Well, I didn't use to
have karaoke at my parties
until I met my wife.
- Why?
So she's better. (laughs)
- She's the karaoke genius.
- So I love her.
- She actually is a genius
at it.
- Okay.
- I mean, it's amazing.
- What's a go-to song
for either one of you?
- Well, she sings Karen Carpenter
like Karen Carpenter couldn't.
(Kelly gasps)
- Oh.
- I mean, it's amazing.
It's clear as bell.
- She's here.
- Yeah, she's here.
She's up there.
- Oh, my gosh.
(audience chuckling)
I love Karen Carpenter.
- [Kelsey] It's amazing.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
when she sings those songs,
"I can take all the madness
the world has to give,"
oh, my God.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- It's just, it's extraordinary,
and it's so clear.
- And an intense life, yeah.
- And she also sings
"Desperado" like
(Kelly gasps)
no one's ever sung it.
- I just sang "Desperado"
here, ma'am.
(audience laughing)
- It's about the sexiest thing
you've ever heard in your life.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- When she says, "Open the
gate," it's like, oh. (chuckles)
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Baby.
- You're like,
"Fine, I will."
(Kelsey laughs)
- Come on.
- (chuckles) You're like,
"I love it."
- Come on in.
- Wait, what's your go-to?
- I tend to sing...
I'll do "Let's Dance" by David Bowie.
(Kelly gasps)
And we have another
distinction that I share
with David Bowie, which
is very interesting.
I had a little heart
trouble about 15 years ago.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And what the nurses
told me was they said,
"Oh, David Bowie was in
this bed before you."
(Kelly gasps)
(audience laughing)
- You're like, "I'm gonna make it."
- I'm like, "Finally,
finally, I've arrived."
- That's amazing.
(audience laughing)
- And then-
- What a random-
- And the guy in before him
was Paul Newman.
So I was like-
- Are are you serious?
- Obviously, they're probably
not supposed to tell you,
but that particular-
- Does this person only work
on super famous people?
(audience laughing)
I was like, weird.
- I think that
it was that room, apparently,
so it's pretty great.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah.
- But back to "Frasier."
- Back to "Frasier."
- Because I'm very excited.
(audience laughing)
So back in Boston.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] So this was all purposeful.
- Well-
- This is like full circle
from Tuesdays, yeah.
- At first, I wanted to...
I wanted to bring the
whole legacy cast back
but in a different world
where we all moved on
to something else-
- Yeah.
- But we would still
be connected.
That didn't work out.
- Okay.
- So once that happened,
after about three years
of really trying to kinda
sell that idea to everybody,
I went home and thought,
well, what do we do now?
And I actually, in a dream, I said,
"Oh, he's gotta go back to Boston.
He hasn't finished.
He didn't leave Boston the right way."
- Yeah.
- The original concept was that he had
to get all the way across the country
'cause we just wanted
to get away from Boston
to start the new show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But that was just a kind of
a geographical happenstance.
I thought, in this one, he left,
the thing with Diane didn't work out,
Lilith and he got divorced,
his son has been in Boston ever since.
I thought, he's got stuff-
- Freddy.
- He's gotta do
in Boston still.
- Yeah.
- And so when he went there
as a young man to first go to Harvard,
it didn't work out the
way he wanted it to.
And so he had some stuff-
- That's beautiful.
- To deal with, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So we're back in Boston.
- And so relatable.
- [Kelsey] Yeah.
- I love that there's a
tribute to John Mahoney,
who played your father.
- Yeah.
- Is that the name of the bar?
- Mahoney's Bar, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Kelsey] The baby's name is John.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The son...
- Ah.
- Daphne and Niles'-
- Ah, loved him.
- And Eddie, ah.
Yeah, you have no idea.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- I have...
- But yeah, John died a few years back,
and I just thought, well,
we can't do the show again
without honoring John.
We just can't.
- Yeah.
- And it has to begin with
the fact that John is gone
and Dad's gone,
Martin's gone.
- Yeah.
- And so then I become Dad, you know?
- Oh, my gosh.
Okay, my makeup artist will kill me.
(audience laughing)
I'm a contagious crier,
so I'm like...
- Yeah, me too.
(all laughing)
- I'm gonna be fine. (sniffles)
Just yeah, okay.
In Boston, though, you're back there,
so do you think any "Cheers"
characters will come in
and out, do you think?
- No, no.
- [Kelly] No?
- [Kelsey] I mean, look-
- Don't let me down, "Cheers" people!
(audience laughing)
I was like, that would be amazing.
Just one.
- The bar is closed.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- I mean, Jimmy's decided that
the bar went out of business.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For whatever reason.
But I would like to see Diane come back.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just for one of those
reasons of Frasier being able
to put something to bed,
to end up with a nice thing-
- Closure.
- Between them, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And to kind of rediscover how much...
'Cause when I first got the role,
the key to Frasier for
me was that he loved her
with his whole heart, that he
loved with all of his being.
And that actually defined who he is.
He's been that way ever since.
- Yeah.
- He just goes in
wholeheartedly with everything
and that's what makes him funny.
- Yeah, so witty.
Oh, my gosh.
God, I'm just so excited
(audience cheering)
the show is back on.
The level of wit is ah, and the elitism
is just so funny.
- It's still there,
yeah, yeah.
- Oh, my God, I love it,
still there.
I have to say this, too.
Speaking of your wife we
were talking about earlier,
y'all, you're celebrating
your anniversary soon, right?
- February 25th, yeah.
- [Kelsey] And you were
married in New York City.
- We were married on the
stage of the Longacre Theatre
where I was performing
"La Cage aux Folles."
- [Kelly] What?
- So Kayte and I met when I
rehearsed that, actually, and-
- Ah, that's magical.
- That's when we fell in love.
Well, the show is about love.
We fell in love.
It just was a perfect combination.
- Ah.
- Then we had a-
- What a movie.
- We had the ceremony on the stage,
and then we had our
reception at The Plaza.
And people still talk about that.
It was really fun.
- Oh, man, the reception.
Let's talk.
Yeah, that's the one-
- It was really great.
- To talk about, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Weddings, I'm always like,
(Kelsey laughs)
meh.
The receptions-
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- That's where the people
come out, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
- It's like little liquid courage,
and you see who really
wanted to be a dancer.
- Yup.
- You know?
(all laughing)
It's amazing.
- They were all dancers at ours.
- I know, that's what I'm saying.
Like, "Oh, yeah, I was totally
gonna be a dancer once."
I love wedding receptions
(audience laughing)
so much.
(Kelsey laughs)
Yeah.
But, so wait, so your kids,
they range from seven to 40.
- Yes.
- So that's a-
- Wow.
- Do you feel, I know.
♪ Hey ♪
(audience laughing)
(Kelsey laughs)
I got a, "Hey!"
(audience laughing)
- When you were first introducing
this lovely young woman up here,
I thought you were gonna actually say,
"We have a big surprise for you, Kelsey,
(audience and Kelly laughing)
because one of the children
you don't know about..."
(all laughing)
- Oh, my God. (laughs)
- I know... (laughs)
- Oh, my God.
- I know it's
a recurring nightmare for my wife, so.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God, that's amazing.
You are so funny.
(audience laughing)
Wait, but I do have a question
because I feel like I
had kids later in life
than a lot of my friends.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I feel like I
think I'm better for it,
starting later in life.
- Yeah.
- Do you think that you're a different dad
from the younger batch
than the older batch?
- Sure.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, I mean, yeah.
I mean, I had more stuff to
figure out when I was younger.
I mean, I still had the-
- Everyone does.
- I still had the war to fight.
I still had the battle to become who I am.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that takes up a lot of time.
- Mm-hmm.
- And so sometimes having kids
is wonderful, you think it's a
good thing, you do your best,
but you miss some things.
- Yeah.
- And I missed some things
with my older kids, there's no question.
The beauty is that God
and life has given me a
chance to make up for it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To kinda try to patch it
all up and make it good,
so I'm doing my best to do that.
- Faith is a big thing for you, right?
- A very big thing, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah,
this is.
- I think
that's very important
to know something more-
- Well, I chased faith
through all my life when I was little.
I went to Sunday school at
a Christian Science school,
and whenever the woman would say,
"Who would like to read this
passage from the Bible?"
I thought, I'd like to read it.
And I think that actually
taught me my love of language.
I think my love of the word, right,
of the English language
came from reading the Bible.
- Yeah.
- And so I would walk
kinda hand in hand with
the idea of God's Word,
and God, and Jesus, and stuff like that.
And then, of course, I had...
Some very difficult things
happened in my life.
And I went through the
classic, I cursed God
and said, "No, thanks.
I don't need your help.
I'd rather just handle this alone
if this is the way it's gonna be."
And then what's interesting
is it never occurred to me
to say, "Oh, what are you up to?"
Meaning the enemy, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- (chuckles) It's like,
nobody ever says to God-
- Trying to get in there,
yeah.
- Oh, says to the other guy,
"I don't appreciate
what you've done here."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We always go, "God, why
did you let this happen?"
Well, maybe he didn't let it happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Maybe it's a not today, Satan.
- Maybe somebody else came
and got-
- Yeah.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, right?
Exactly.
- That's what I say.
Not today, sir.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes, you will not get this girl's joy.
- So I carry that with me a lot.
And eventually, I just kinda
got back on track and met-
- That's beautiful.
- Remet Jesus,
I guess you could say,
and I carry Him with me,
and it's been a great thing.
- [Kelly] That's very beautiful.
And that kinda testimony
is so powerful, too,
to tell everybody.
(audience applauding)
That's cool.
So I have to say this.
I mean, you're from "Cheers" originally,
and now you own a brewery,
and I think that's amazing.
- Oh, yeah, I know.
- [Kelly] You own a brewery Upstate,
right?
- Yeah, yeah,
I do.
- I love Upstate New York.
Do you love it?
- I absolutely adore it, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, Faith American Brewing Company.
- Yeah.
- That's what I named-
- What was your...
Why did you wanna do that?
- The water.
- Yeah.
- I've had this property
up there for 26 years.
- Yeah.
- And I'd walk the trails
and hike and stuff,
and see the water and think,
"Gosh, we ought to do
something with this."
It used to be a really,
really successful place,
prosperous place.
It was a dairy farm and
a big cauliflower farm,
the largest cauliflower farm
in the East Coast for years.
- Wow.
- And old folks who'd
come from that town say,
"Oh, yeah, I used to pack
cauliflower (indistinct) up there
at your old place."
And I go, "Yeah, okay." (chuckles)
- There's none there now, sorry.
- They also used to trap black minks.
- Yeah.
- So obviously,
that's a different story, too.
- Yeah.
- In any case, the beer
seemed like the natural thing.
And my wife actually
suggested the beer as well.
- Yeah.
- And we go through
a big battle about that.
- She's got great ideas.
- Yeah, she said-
(audience laughing)
- Karaoke, alcohol.
I'm very into her.
- "You did the beer
because I said so."
(audience laughing)
And I said, "I know.
I never thought of it before."
(Kelly laughs)
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] I like her already.
- [Kelsey] Yeah.
- We have a game next.
You wanna play a game?
- Yeah, I heard this game-
- Okay.
- We're gonna play, okay.
- Well,
(all laughing)
I'm just saying it's good
that you have faith in God
and prayer 'cause you're gonna need it.
- Okay. (chuckles)
(audience cheering)
- Yes, I'm competitive.
(Kelsey laughs)
Well, we sang the "Frasier"
theme song earlier.
And up next, we've got a game about some
of the best TV show
theme songs of all time,
which I love.
- Ooh.
- Be sure to watch "Frasier"
on Paramount+, everybody.
We'll be right back.
(Kelly claps)